oh I'm Karen Gillan I'm Jack Black and
this is first impressions for a lad by
Paul you should go first
oh oh it's a Mario Brothers it's a Super
Mario oh I said the brothers need the
brother I did I need the brother he's on
it you gone all right tweeting no I was
just doing this up you're a dancer off
the top of my head yes and it launched
but the thing is that I'm coming up with
it from the top of my head and I make it
up I make it up yes but what is that
call when you're rapping improvise all
right I'm going in for another one are
you ready the most ridiculous
impersonation of Arnold Schwarzenegger
oh it sounds like a frog vomiting that's
genius that you actually picked that and
you had to state that it's a beautiful
it's a bit of a laugh
[Applause]
oh okay
[Music]
is it
[Laughter]
all right I'm going in for another one
are you ready you saying tribute right
I'm famous for smoking a lot of pot okay
I don't know if this is what it's gotta
be in that family it's not chimpanzee
gorilla orangutan
[Music]
you know what it is but
[Applause]